the UN is predicting 130 million people
around the world might die not because
of coronavirus but because of the
economic shutdowns associated with
coronavirus is it still all worth it to
save just one life Governor Cuomo the
new numbers expose a fundamental moral
error on the left that's been around a
lot longer than the virus then failed
Georgia gubernatorial candidate Stacey
Abrams begins to openly campaign to be
Joe Biden's running mate Alec Baldwin
inadvertently reveals some spiritual
truths about quarantine and finally the
mailbag I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
by the way please do let me know who you
think Joe Biden's VP running mate will
be in the comment section this is
obviously a very big question because
I'm not sure that Joe Biden is still
even walking around in campaigning sort
of like the Kim jong-un problem I just
don't know is he still there is he not I
don't know so let me know in the
comments also we've got to thank our
friends over at ebb sleep very important
these days more important than ever and
yet it's harder to get good sleep
because of these uncertain and anxious
times Abe comfortably cools your
forehead helps quiet the racing mind and
promotes the natural onset of sleep it
is so cool EV is the first and only
wearable drug-free solution that targets
the root cause of sleeplessness which is
those racing thoughts AB is clinically
validated okay and four out of five
users report falling asleep faster and
improving overall sleep quality AB sleep
is a wearable solution that fits over
the forehead and gently and precisely
cools the forehead to reduce those
racing thoughts to allow people who are
suffering from sleep lessness drift more
comfortably into a deeper more
restorative sleep I love this thing I
tried it on it's it's amazing how it
works it just starts pumping this very
cool relaxing I don't even know what it
is it goes around your head it feels
really great and it is now clinically
shown to help you fall asleep AB sleep
understands the uncertainty you may be
experiencing at this time they want to
help you and save twenty five bucks off
your order by using promo code Knolls to
save continue to try at risk free for 60
nights to confirm it's the solution
you've been looking for
try abdominals let us help you get the
sleep you need and remove the risk from
your purchase TR ye be be calm
/ Knowles tribe calm / you Knowles use
promo code Knowles to save order today
with everything going on get the sleep
you need and deserve oh okay
if the lock downs save just one life and
it will have all been worth it right
that is what New York's governor and
equal moe told us in the last couple
weeks now CNN is picking up on a news
story that all of us normal people
figured out almost at the begin
this pandemic namely that there could be
negative effects of the lockdowns
themselves CNN runs a tweet quote the
world is facing multiple famines of
biblical proportions in just a matter of
months the UN has said warning that the
corona virus pandemic will push an
additional 130 million people to the
brink of starvation now that is not
precise the point is true but that is
not precise the corona virus is not
going to push 130 million people to the
brink of starvation because the corona
virus doesn't starve anybody the
economic shutdowns that were chosen by
the government will possibly push 130
million people to the brink of
starvation obviously we couldn't have
predicted it would be a hundred thirty
million or a hundred twenty million or a
hundred forty million but every normal
person every non leftist person realized
at the beginning of this that when you
shut down the global economy there are
going to be negative consequences from
that okay this is no surprise to anybody
except apparently the UN and CNN so how
does this new number change Cuomo's
calculation if we only if we can save
even one life then it'll all be worth it
what does any Cuomo sound like Bernie
Sanders I don't know they're both from
New York I guess almost calculation was
always extremely stupid
okay Cuomo's calculation first of all
it's supposed that you could shut down
the global economy with any without any
negative consequences that's crazy
and it also supposed that the doomsday
models were reliable so when you said
two to four million Americans could die
they just assumed okay that's fine now
four million Americans are gonna die
okay yeah you got to shut down the
economy you got to take his extreme
measure as you can but what's the
likelihood of that well we quickly
learned it wasn't that likely it's four
million and two million then half a
million and 100,000 and now they're
saying somewhere around sixty thousand
who knows between sixty and a hundred
thousand obviously much more in line
with drug overdoses in the flu than it
would be in line with four million or
two million people dying now that all of
these numbers are crashing down around
Cuomo people are asking real questions
namely the question that those of us who
have been a little skeptical of the
government here have been asking for
weeks what do we do if the
or is worse than the disease and Andy
Cuomo is having none of it it's a very
serious question but he's having none of
it because according to the leftists
according to people with this narrow
ideology the Cure can't possibly be
worse than the disease and and this is a
really important point because it
exposes not just Cuomo's factual idiocy
but his moral idiocy and a moral
adhesive that is widespread on the Left
these are regular people who are not
getting a paycheck some of them are not
getting their unemployment check and
they're saying that they don't have time
to wait for all of this testing and they
need to get back to work in order to
feed their families their savings is
running out they don't have another week
they're not getting answers so their
point is that cure can't be worse than
the illness itself what is your response
to that the illness is death
what is worse than death if somebody
commits suicide because they can't pay
their but the illnesses may be my death
as opposed to your death you said they
said the cure is worse than the illness
the illness is death how can the Cure be
worse than the illness if the illness is
potential death so this is idiocy of the
highest order factually and morally on
the factual point he's just wrong the
illness is not death in fact that's what
we've learned more and more each day of
this pandemic if you contract
coronavirus the likelihood that you will
die is exceedingly low like way way low
like like initially they told us it was
three to four percent now they're saying
it'll may be 0.6% maybe 0.3 percent
maybe 0.1% we don't know it keeps going
down and down each day because it turns
out more and more people are affected
we're getting news that that Los Angeles
had a or California or either headed
death from coronavirus on February 6
which means it was here much much
earlier than anybody thought it was it
might be even earlier than that and if
it was earlier than that that explained
why it spread so much and why that death
rate has gone down so when he says the
but the illness is death that is
just simply not true but here's the
moral idiocy is he says what can be
worse than death there's nothing worse
than death death is the worst thing
that's not true there are many things
worse than death
like okay for all of the history of our
civilization we have believed that death
is a very very bad thing but there are
things that are worse than death this
was the thesis of Ronald Reagan's famous
time for choosing speech one of the most
famous speeches of the 20th century
he said if if there's nothing worse than
death
then should Moses have refused to lead
the Israelites out of Egypt should
Christ have refused the cross should the
Patriots a conquered bridge have refused
to fire the shot heard around the world
there are things that are worse than
death you know during the Cold War there
were two sides here there was better
dead than red right those who would
rather die than live on our knees and
those who said better red than dead
they'd rather live on their knees than
die on their feet and Cuomo is
expressing that point of view he's he is
actually expressing the point of view
that he would that there is nothing
worse in life than dying
nothing worth standing up for it this is
the height of cowardice now the reporter
pushes him on this and says well what
about some of the other externalities
here what about some of the other
effects he goes point by point he says
yes your things are bad if you're stuck
at home with an abusive spouse domestic
abuse is bad but that's not worse than
death nothing is worse than death at
home it doesn't equal death economic
hardship yes very bad not death
emotional stress from being locked in a
house very bad not death
domestic violence on the increase very
bad not death and not death of someone
else see that's what we have to factor
into this equation yeah it's your life
do whatever you want but you're not
responsible for my life you have a
responsibility to me it's not just about
you you have a responsibility to me that
could be Andy Cuomo's mantra for the
whole pandemic and certainly for his
governorship you've got a responsibility
to me forget about you worry about me
nothing is worse than death could you
imagine if we had an army full of Andy
Cuomo's we'd be dead we'd all be dead
because nobody would have any courage
what Andrew Cuomo is saying right here
is don't ever have any courage don't
ever risk your life for anything don't
consider anything greater than yourself
and if you do consider something greater
than yourself remember that something is
me me governor Andy Cuomo this idea is
profoundly unchristian profoundly
unamerican we just celebrated Easter and
equal moe pretends that he's a Catholic
what is the story of Easter the story of
Easter is God so loving the world that
He gave His only begotten Son to die to
redeem mankind but there's nothing worse
than death okay all right well fair
enough then I guess there's nothing no
greater love has a man than to die for
his friends no but nothing's worse than
death of course there are many things
that are worse than death we have to
calculate what that is where that line
is are we saying that people should
recklessly endanger their lives no of
course not
however are we saying that we should
shut down the global economy if you
don't have to do that if that's gonna
cost more lives if there's something in
the calculus beyond just life I mean
this has been the problem with Andy
Cuomo's calculus the whole time he says
if we can save one life and law be worth
it you know there are more factors here
to consider than just that
it turns out that he's even wrong on his
calculation of this many people will
live in this many people will die you
got that completely wrong too apparently
by about 130 million but even beyond
that there are things in life other than
mere survival and if Andy Cuomo
understood this then he his view of the
world would be a far less perverted he
is finally asked point-blank what if
people want to work what if people need
to work what if people can't feed their
families
he gives the most glib arrogant
condescending answer he possibly could
have saying that is there a fundamental
right to work if the government can't
get me the money when I need it is there
you want to work work work
go take the job as an essential worker
do it tomorrow yeah you want to go work
that's fine do what I tell you to do can
you think of a less essential worker
than Andrew Cuomo I can Chris Cuomo is
lying brother over at CNN but actually I
don't know maybe it's a competition
between those two Cuomo's I used to
think Chris was the Fredo of the family
now I'm not so sure what did what a glib
answer what that's the answer of a guy
who's never had to worry about having a
job is he's worked in government his
whole life yeah you want it yeah you
want to get a job go become an essential
worker well guess what we're learning
we're learning that all workers are
essential because the UN is saying 130
million people are gonna starve to death
because you shut down the global economy
the essential workers are still working
right but it turns out everybody's
essential Cuomo apparently doesn't
understand that the left doesn't quite
understand that
AOC another New Yorker does not
understand that the moral idiocy is not
merely on questions of life and death
it gets down to work and the nature of
man itself and leave it to AOC to get
that totally wrong we'll get that in a
second first I got to thank our friends
over at Express VPN you know everybody
is working from home these days right
unfortunately I would say most of you
don't have the IT department around to
protect you that is why I recommend
using a VPN that I use and Trust
expressvpn
for the best online protection possible
okay I've been talking about expressvpn
on my show for so long now that you
already understand why encrypting your
net
data is so important but some of you
still haven't done it that doesn't make
sense
you might be thinking the security
threats they're not gonna affect you
right there for somebody else they're
not for you not using Express VPN is
like leaving your front door unlocked
every time you go out and let me tell
you something if you're listening to
this show you probably look at some
stuff on the internet that maybe you
don't want people to see you know you go
to that incognito window and you type in
daily wire comm you know what I mean
you know what I mean my only question is
why haven't you gotten expressvpn yet
visit my special link right now Express
VPN comm slash michael mi CH AE I'll get
an extra three months of expressvpn for
free protects your Internet today with
the VPN that I use and I trust to keep
my data safe expressvpn comm slash
Michael
so Cuomo gets the life-and-death issue
wrong it doesn't know what life is
doesn't know what the significance of
death is the left doesn't get this at
all actually Alec Baldwin the celebrity
shows us something a little bit about
this and we'll get to that in a moment
what AOC misunderstands is the nature of
man as it relates to work and socialists
generally misunderstand this because
they don't want to work because they're
lazy bums AOC has this brilliant idea
with now we've found out another
something like 5 million people and
another 5 million people are thrown out
of work so it brings the total up to
what 27 28 million people out of work in
the last month she says well I've got an
idea when the pandemic lifts and you're
all desperate to try to get a paycheck
so you can feed yourself and pay your
rent actually what you should do is
refuse to work there's a lot that we
could be doing right now but ultimately
the I think when we talk about this idea
of reopening society you know only in
America does the president when the
president tweets about liberation does
he mean go back to work when we you know
have this discussion about going going
back or reopening I think a lot of
people should just say no we're not
going back to that we're not going back
to working 70 hour weeks just so that we
could put food on the table and not even
feel any sort of some
of security in our lives AOC only works
a 70-hour week what a come on she's like
one of the top politicians in the
country and she thinks 70 hours is a lot
70 hours isn't let's think about how
many people at the top of their fields
get to only work 70 hours a week do you
think Tim Cook at Apple only works 70
hours a week no only in government do
you get to reach the basically the
pinnacle of fame and influence and still
work 70 hours a week
unbelievable beyond that people are
mocking her for this saying oh my gosh
what a crazy she misspoke no she didn't
misspeak she's been campaigning on
keeping people out of work since the
beginning of her political career two
years ago
don't forget the green new deal her
signature legislative project has a
provision in it to just pay people from
the government who are unable or
unwilling to work so you just say I
don't really want to work this year and
you get a paycheck under AFC's plan and
it comes down to this word she uses
liber8 she's mocking Trump she says only
in Trump's America only in this
conservative Republican hellhole could
the word liber8 imply that you have to
work because the left and socialists
have this idea that working is somehow
just a punishment it's miserable it's
awful it's something that humans
shouldn't do they shouldn't have to work
Nancy Pelosi said this she said remember
dirt when during the passage of
Obamacare she said we need to decouple
health insurance from your employment so
that people don't have to work anymore
so that they can go become poets so they
can become writers artists as though
work is holding mankind back and if we
can only stop our need to work then we
could finally flourish but that isn't
true the only way we flourish is by
working okay in the Garden of Eden Adam
had a job to do he had to tend the
garden and name the animals certainly
when they got kicked out of the Garden
of Eden God says by the sweat of your
brow you shall earn your food you work
you have to work now what does that tell
us the fact that the most influential
book and
origins of humanity begins with the
issue of work if every other story about
humanity begins with this kind of work
what does that tell us it tells us that
man is made to work and you know that
you just know this intuitively you know
this right now because you're living it
when you're not allowed to work when
you're thrown out of your job when
you're even if you do get to keep your
job when you're just told to sit at home
and do nothing you get depressed you
don't feel good about yourself you don't
feel satisfied or gratified and when
you're working and when you're working
really hard even if you're working a 70
hour week maybe an 80 hour week and
maybe even a 90 hour week the thing
that's so weird about it is when you're
really in it when you're really
succeeding at your job you feel better
than if you were on vacation at a beach
isn't that weird that's so we shouldn't
expect that right we should think that
the best we're ever gonna feel is with a
pina colada sitting on the beach but it
isn't you actually feel best when you're
accomplishing something doesn't
understand this this is this is part of
the radical liberation that the left and
the Socialists have pushed forward for
200 years now which is we're gonna we're
gonna liberate ourselves so much
emancipate ourselves so much that we
will emancipate ourselves from our own
human nature from the confines of
reality from our biological sex from our
need to work itself and it drives people
absolutely mad those are the two moral
idiots of the Democratic Party right now
the two most prominent Cuomo and AOC the
rest are just of the usual variety the
blathering kind one of those happens to
be the nominee for president
Joe Biden AOC for all that we knock her
she sounds like Winston Churchill
compared to Joe Biden here's Joe Biden
celebrating Earth Day yesterday talking
to former Vice President Al Gore
remember him Savior of the world I don't
know what Joe Biden is talking about
here please take a listen and see if you
can decipher it for me
most Americans now get the challenge
we're facing they believe in science the
issue is important to them and they want
their leaders to act on climate
particularly young people as you said
inspired by the activism of of Greta and
so many so many young Americans as well
who are who are leading on climate you
know
JFK said refusing he said he refused to
postpone you know that one line in his
speech we all had to learn we were kids
about gold the moon and he talked about
you know the one thing that the line
that meant the most to managed to drive
my colleagues crazy was his phrase I
refuse we're doing this because we
refused to postpone well we should say
is the nation I refused to postpone as
president I refused to postpone taking
immediate action and look I'm confident
I'm confident not only can we address
the crisis we can make most of the
opportunity and create 10 million good
jobs make the US the world's clean
energy exporter and more optimistic than
I have been and since I've been a 29
year old kid about what we could do so I
think my favorite part of this entire
exchange or narrative or stream of
consciousness is that he thinks a 29
year old as a kid because to Joe Biden
the 29 year old is a kid but the rest of
it's pretty crazy to the problem that
Joe has is he can't focus his thoughts
anymore he actually did used to be able
to do this but he can't now this is
probably the number one sign that he's
slipping which is that he begins
somewhere and he just meanders and the
thoughts go all over the place and then
by the time he ends he's nowhere near
where he began so frankly in this clip
he was better than he usually is he's at
least talking about the environment but
he starts to wander and he's talking
about Greta and then he's talking about
JFK and then he's talking about when he
was a kid and he learned this speech and
then he can't really remember the line
from the speech and then he says this
line we cannot postpone which is not a
line from the speech JFK does talk about
postponing in the speech but that's not
first of all it's not what Joe Biden
said it's not the central line of the
speech the central line of the speeches
we will go to the moon not because it is
easy but because it is hard that's the
thrust and and Biden doesn't get it he
just misses it a little bit again then
he tries to dig himself out and he ends
up nowhere which is probably where
he belongs and you can see it on the
face of Al Gore this is everyone that
talks to Joe Biden whether it's a
left-wing news broadcaster or it's
Bernie Sanders or it's Al Gore you can
see them split-screen and they got their
good politician face on and then Joe
starts talking and as they're talking
you can see the distress enter onto
their face because they think oh my gosh
what have we done
Donald Trump is gonna win another four
years you might win another eight years
if he clobbers him so badly
that's why Joe Biden needs a strong VP
and there is someone someone who is a
failed politician someone who has never
won anything bigger than a local state
office who is ready to take the job for
him we'll get to that in one second
first I got to thank our friends over at
Wonder E I want to let you know how much
I love crazy weird stories about creepy
hippies you know you already knew that I
didn't have to tell you that what I want
to let you know about is wonder his new
show Americans scandal where they dive
deep into the heart of the most shocking
moments of fraud and deception in
American history and on the hippie point
one of the most fascinating stories in
the American scandal season is the Hari
Krishna murders in this episode they
explore an Eastern religion let's say
it's got totally pure intentions right
but in the hands of these crazy
followers in the West it became a
criminal enterprise of drug running
molestation and murder
subscribe to American scandal and other
great wonder e podcasts right now you
can get them all over the place you get
it on Apple podcast get it on Spotify
you get it wherever you listen to
podcasts obviously we've all got a
little bit more time these days to be
consuming great content I absolutely
love this the whole season is fabulous
but definitely check out those crazy
Hari Krishna murders because it really
it really checks every bucks wild wacky
politics murder mayhem deception go
check it out right now somebody is
willing to take the spot as Joe Biden's
vice president that person is not
necessarily a sitting US
or sitting u.s. governor or a former US
governor or former US senator or anybody
who's held any office higher than a
local state rep and that person would be
Stacey Abrams a lot of people are
looking to you as a possible vice
presidential pick for Joe Biden now I
love it
you said you would be an excellent
running mate it's refreshing to hear
such confidence I love it I would be
great at the job and I want it you said
so tell us why you would be an excellent
running running mate even though it's
pretty obvious to me well I appreciate
that pretty obvious to me how is it
obvious to you joy what has she done her
highest office she's ever had is a local
state rep not a US rap not a not a
congressman even like a local state rep
in Georgia there are millions of people
more qualified to be vice president than
Stacey Abrams this is just what the
women of the view do is they speak
without thinking I had sort of the
definition of the view but joy here just
likes the idea of Stacey Abrams for what
reason we'll get to that in a second so
she says oh you'd be perfect you'd be so
qualified I mean it's so obvious to me
but yeah listen since I can't quite name
it right now what do you think it's like
that time that Whoopi Goldberg a few
weeks ago said I think doctor dr. Jill
Biden should be the Surgeon General and
the other woman said about what she was
yeah she's an amazing doctor she's an
amazing they said no actually I would be
I think it's like she's a doctor of
Education actually it's not a she's a
teacher she's not a doctor oh okay and
they just talk at it because they like
the idea of these Democratic politicians
especially if they check some
intersectional boxes like Joe Biden
Stacey Abrams so they just say things
that have no connection to reality
Stacey Abrams though is prepared with an
answer tell us why you would be an
excellent running running mate even
though it's pretty obvious to me well I
appreciate that
and yes I try to be straightforward
because well we hope the work speaks for
itself sometimes the work needs a hike
man and I and I learned early on that if
I didn't speak for myself
couldn't tell the story but here's where
I am I've spent the last 25 years of my
life in service doing the work that I
believe needs to be done is there
anything more grating than when a career
politician refers to their work
exclusively as service I've I've
listened my I'm a martyr I'm mother
Teresa basically I've served you because
I went to law school and then I'm
absolutely hungry and I crave political
power and so I ran for the first office
I could and I've been paid by your
taxpayer dollars ever since to do in
Stacey Abrams case absolutely nothing
I'm just a real servant
you know I'm practically a missionary or
a martyr yep that's me also there's more
evidence here that Stacey Abrams is not
qualified to run a coffee shop much less
to run as vice president of the United
States Stacey Abrams doesn't know what a
hype man is she said look you hope the
work speaks for itself in Stacey Abrams
this case it doesn't cuz she hasn't done
anything but she said but sometimes the
work needs a hype man yeah a hype man is
someone who isn't you the hype man is
the guy who isn't the main person who
goes and chats up how wonderful the work
is but because Stacey Abrams hasn't
accomplished anything and she's just a
loser she's known nationally for having
lost a race she's got to be her own hype
man it's very ugly it's very off-putting
it's just a woman who seems very
prideful boasting about things she has
not accomplished and complaining about
offices that she hasn't won so then
finally she makes the case for all that
work that we need the hype man for what
do you say to critics who say that you
aren't qualified for vice president
because you've only held state office I
would say that national experience can
be measured in multiple ways and the
truth of the matter is what we want is
capacity we want competence and we want
skills and I would challenge anyone to
look at my resume and to understand that
I've built three national organizations
in the last year-and-a-half
tackling the most fundamental questions
in our country and I'm not stopping
simply because they're people who
dislike what
do I'm working on it because my
responsibility is to serve the people
like me like my parents like my cousins
who are working in chicken processing
plants and who are worried about where
their next paycheck comes from and who
deserve a government that can be
responsive and if I'm not willing to say
that's work I can do and back it up with
a resume that shows I've done that work
then I shouldn't be in the in the
business I'm in right you shouldn't
because you've proof that you can't do
that work you were a state rep for ten
years and then you tried to run for
governor and you lost that's it there's
the proof not even just that you lost a
race but you didn't really do anything
when you were a state Rep she's built
three national organizations over the
last year what does that mean what are
the names of the organizations one of
those organizations accomplished do you
know how easy it is to write down to
start a political action committee or
something or a non-profit and you know
you get one donation in California and
one donation in New York you say I've
got a national organization sure it's
what you organized something I guess
what does it do what is its name we have
no idea
three national organizations and we
haven't heard of any of them man that's
pretty sad they're tackling the most
fundamental questions in the country how
what are they doing she isn't doing
anything she hasn't ever done anything
the only reason that she is being
considered is because the Democratic
Party is obsessed with sex and race so
just to begin Joe Biden says I am gonna
pick a woman we're I don't care who's
most qualified I don't doesn't matter to
me I'm just gonna pick a woman because
that will help me pander to my base and
so they say okay we're gonna pick a
woman now many Democrats have said it's
got to be a woman of color so now we've
got race race added to sex here those
are the two qualifications and yeah sure
Stacey Abrams checks the intersectional
boxes of victimhood
is that gonna put her in the best
position as I can put the Democrats in
the best position to win you just check
a couple superficial identity boxes
instead of looking at any
accomplishments which Stacey Abrams
completely lacks there are millions of
Americans more qualified than her to be
Joe Biden's running mate okay I don't
think this is gonna help them I don't
think it's gonna help them because what
the Democrats are playing on here
is they think that these intersectional
victim identity boxes now matters more
than how you can help in the electoral
college so they think that around the
country people are gonna look and
they'll say well Joe Biden maybe I don't
care for him that much but Stacey Abrams
is black so I'm gonna vote for her or
Stacey Abrams is a woman so I'm gonna
vote for her or whatever whatever the
the identity group is usually
historically people have picked vice
presidents to help them win a certain
state is Joe Biden gonna win Georgia
probably not probably Georgia is gonna
go for Trump Stacey Avery was gonna help
him win Georgia probably not she lost
the governor's race now Brian camp is
the governor so she doesn't add anything
in terms of picking up a new state
should they think she they just think
people's sexual and racial solidarity is
gonna outweigh the importance of winning
the state or that state I don't think
there's any evidence of that I think
they're going to regret that decision if
they pick Stacey Abrams which is why I'm
now fully behind Stacey Abrams for for
Joe's running mate before we get to the
mailbag I've got to thank our friends
over at beard supply look me I'm clean
shaven unfortunately because I have been
checking out beard supply I now really
really want to grow one trouble is I can
grow a full beard except like right here
so I don't know what I'm gonna have to
put mascara there or something
you thought quarantine was your chance
to try something new didn't you you
thought like me to let down on your
facial hair join the ranks of the
bearded breath brethren well you must
have missed the memo because the beard
isn't just fun and games all right it's
not some fifth-grade science experiment
with Mentos and soda it is a sacred art
and beard Supply is leading you to the
promised land by now you've discovered a
full healthy beard is not just something
you can order on Amazon Prime no way
more often than not your beard is dry
itchy patchy and at its worst is a
sparse it's the face mask aisle of your
local hardware store beard supplies 100%
natural oils change all of that it's
absolutely fabulous a head on over right
now to beard supply for a limited time
beard supplies offering my listeners 25%
off go-to beard supply.com use the promo
code
NOLs for 25% off all oil soaps balms
grooming supplies beard supply.com promo
code Knowles your beard can be so much
better go to beard supply.com
today you know before we get to the
mailbag just one quick note from Alec
Baldwin Alec Baldwin is stuck at home
he's absolutely losing his mind and it
doesn't just show us something about the
psyche of Alec Baldwin it shows us a
spiritual reality a block down hey
normally probably wouldn't do this kind
of thing but if it gained ow then I wake
up the word about house and thinking
about what's happening what's going to
happen this is harder it is a little
harder every day because I think less
about myself than the people I care for
okay it remains as crazy if not crazier
than that for the whole rest of this
rambling video he goes on about a bunch
of nonsense about the economic impact if
the lockdown I don't care about any of
them I am more interested in how
completely insane Alec Baldwin looks and
if you will allow me to engage in a
little psychobabble here I think it
shows us something about the lockdowns
which is most people don't need to be
alone very much some people do and you
know that's unpleasant sometimes but it
can be very spiritually edifying if you
don't have to be alone very much and now
you do have to be alone that can be a
scary prospect when all the dinners go
away and all going out to the bars and
all constantly doing this and then
you're just sitting alone with yourself
then the only person you're gonna be
with is yourself and your god also you
know but some people are not exactly
aware of that and they have to look at
who they are and they have to look at
what their lives are full of and what
their lives mean without all the
distractions we are so prone to being
distracted especially in this very
luxurious prosperous culture and society
that we live in that we ignore the
fundamental questions we ignore the
fundamental
facts of life we ignore the memento mori
which the pandemic reminds us of that we
are going to die and all this great
glitzy stuff and all the nice jewelry
and all the fancy food and drinks it's
going away you don't get to take it with
you that can be a wonderful thing to
confront it can make your life so much
better if you confront it this could be
a wonderful opportunity to look into
that or it can be absolutely terrifying
and you can end up with your hair
standing up like muttering to yourself
like a crazy person like Alec Baldwin
those are the two options
seems like you know if you got to turn
lemons into lemonade
that would be a good way to use this
pandemic is to address the things that
are beyond not just the walls of your
apartment but the walls of this life all
right let's get to the mailbag you know
obviously we appreciate all the
subscribers right now if you become an
insider plus or all-access member you
won't just get one leftist ears tumblr
you will get are you ready for it are
you ready can you guess what you're
gonna get you're gonna get two leftist
tears Tumblr's oh man what a deal twice
as good head on over to daily wire.com
slash subscribe we will be right back
with the mailbag
I'm gonna fly through this mail bag I'm
gonna squeeze in more answers into this
seven minutes than I usually do into 15
from Eric mr. Knowles
I was wondering if there was some advice
you could give me my wife has a hard
time having faith in a higher power due
to an assault when she was young I
wanted to know if there's anything you
might be able to think of to help her
find God's love and find her way back to
religion very sorry to hear that that
happened to your wife that can be a big
stumbling block we saw this in the
church sex scandals and the Catholic
Church sex scandals and the Baptist sex
scandals and in all of them when you
have your faith shaken by an assault
whether it's a priest or a pastor just
some guy you know that can make you
really question the world what you've
got to tell your wife I hope this
doesn't sound cold I think this is
actually the most compassionate fact you
can tell her is that whether or not God
exists has nothing to do with our
subjective feelings and experiences in
the world that's not the question it's
not God is not just a feeling okay God
if he exists is a fact and that fact is
objective and it's outside of us the
arguments for the existence of God are
compelling and there are many of them
you can just google arguments for the
existence of God the tow mystic
arguments are good from st. Thomas
Aquinas or from other people as well the
arguments against the existence of God
are not good I can only think of one the
only argument against the existence of
God which ties into your wife's
experience is suffering senseless
suffering why does why does a kid get
abused why does a kid get leukemia why
why do bad things happen to good people
that is one of the argument that there
is suffering in the world but of course
all of the great religious thinkers have
had a simple answer to this which is
that mankind has free will that it is a
fact of the world that sin and death
pervade it
and the rain falls on the just and the
unjust alike so now you might get to the
point where you say ok God exists but
he's a jerk because he's given us this
world where abuse happens ok maybe
though this actually still is the
greatest possible world maybe the world
with incarnation and atonement the world
in which God so loved the world that He
gave His only begotten Son that
whosoever should believe in Him might
not perish but have everlasting life
maybe that is the greatest possible
world maybe a world without free will
where there's no sin and death would
actually be worse than a world in which
there is free will we can pursue our own
desires and we can pursue the good as we
see the good and we can choose to do
what we want to do is better even if
there's sin and death because God will
redeem that world and God has redeemed
that world there's so much more to it
than that hopefully that will be an
introduction to your wife and I wish you
luck from Jeff hi Michael I'm a huge fan
of your show I'm sure you've heard of
the queue a non-movement my question is
do you see any validity to the movement
or do you dismiss it as just another
conspiracy theory I'm not sold as to
believe a certain way on it but hoping
you could maybe shed some light on it
thanks for any answer and again I love
your show I specifically became a member
just for your show thank you very much I
appreciate it yes I have heard of the
queue non-movement but I don't know very
much about it I haven't looked into it
too closely so I give my answer just on
conspiracy theories in general I
I don't like conspiracy theories I
always go for the simpler explanation
than the conspiracy theory explanation
the reason that conspiracy theories
catch on however is when there are
conspiracies and by that I'm not talking
about any conspiracy in particular I'm
talking about when we can't trust the
people who are supposed to tell us the
truth so the media here are the big
culprits the media have lied to us time
and time again you saw Chris Cuomo
pretending to walk out of his basement
for the first time in weeks even though
we know that he got caught outside of
his house and he lies right on TV right
to your face and so we say well wait a
second I can't believe those guys there
actually is some sort of a conspiracy
right
there's the CNN Chris Cuomo conspiracy
there all these other lies that come out
and that gives more credence to
conspiracy theories conspiracy theories
should be judged on their predictive
ability right because the way they're
usually judged is by this 20/20 ex post
facto explain in Reverse kind of thing
like Nostradamus you know their
Nostradamus predicted everything no one
knew that at the time but when you look
backwards it looks like he predicted
everything you you've got to look not
just to the explanatory power looking
backward but to the predictive power
looking forward if this particular
theory can predict things into the
future and you can actually say okay ten
days this is going to happen and then it
happens then I guess there's a reason to
give some credence to it if it can't do
that then probably it's not worth as
much as it says it is from Chris to the
all-knowing Knowles longtime listener
first-time caller I disagree that
abortion is a right however it is
currently a medical procedure typically
performed by medical professionals if we
make it illegal to get an abortion I'm
afraid that some desperate individuals
will still attempt to abort their
pregnancies do-it-yourself style how do
we move forward in our fight to end
abortion while simultaneously removing
the only option to safely perform the
operation yeah this is one of the lines
that the left is used forever they've
said that before roe v wade five
thousand ten thousand women a year died
from botched back-alley abortions that's
not true the guy who came up with that
statistic dr. Bernard Nathanson
the one of the founders of the
pro-abortion movement founder of nay
role he ended up changing his views and
becoming a pro-life advocate later in
his life he said that they just made
those numbers up out of whole cloth we
actually know that because we can look
at the Centers for Disease Control
numbers the year before Roe vs. Wade you
had something like 35 or 39 deaths from
back-alley abortions now 39,000 about 39
million 39 . do you know how many deaths
you had from legal abortions that year
24 and when you look at which states had
legal and illegal abortion it turns out
that the likelihood of being killed by a
legal abortion or an illegal abortion
was statistically almost exactly the
same that's not a real fear meanwhile
million babies a year are being killed
to abortion
this is just not not a difficult issue
an abortion you say it's being performed
by medical professionals that's true but
that is criminal you know medical
professionals take an oath to do no harm
and and some doctors have decided to to
use their medical gifts to kill people
million million a year it's it's not a
difficult issue from Kevin most
excellent Michael Knowles my wife seems
to be developing leftist views such as
distancing herself from our Catholic
faith pro socialism pro-abortion she's
also said very strange things in a
recent argument she started not sure if
I love you at cetera
yikes I'm interested in marriage
counseling but I'm nervous about being
outnumbered we live in Silicon Valley
she is my high school sweetheart we've
been together for 15 years were engaged
for two and married for just over two
now she asked to wait until we finish
school to get married but we've been
together uninterrupted we also chose to
wait until marriage which I'm incredibly
happy we did it made everything
incredibly special any insider help came
for been subscribed for Knowles and
Clavin
very sorry to hear that you're in this
predicament you're absolutely right to
have this fear that you're gonna be
outnumbered in marriage counseling you
don't remember I'm sure there are plenty
of good marriage counselors who have all
sorts of different ideologies but in
order for marriage counseling to work
you you need to all agree on what
marriage is going in there actually has
to be some guardrails and constraints
around here because now we've redefined
marriage to mean just about anything so
the Catholic view of marriage is very
different than the modern secular view
of marriage and you've got to figure out
what you're even going to try to fix if
you want to try to create or repair or
some modern secular marriage that's
gonna look a lot different and be a lot
less satisfying then trying to repair a
Catholic marriage okay the Catholic view
first of all is you can't get divorced
there is no divorce a marriage can be
annulled if it was illegitimate to begin
with but there's no divorce and so the
attitude going in is gonna be a lot
different than the modern marriage which
is like you know if you have a tiff one
night then you're gonna split up you
should go to marriage counseling if your
wife will do it that can be very helpful
I would recommend you say you're
Catholic probably you want
a Catholic marriage that you find a
Catholic faithfully Catholic marriage
counselor not a you know cafeteria
Catholic marriage counselor but someone
who actually believes in this stuff and
if your wife is unwilling to do that
then you've got to have a conversation
first about what it is you're even
trying to fix people go down bad
intellectual roads or spiritual roads or
make bad decisions at some point so you
know it's easy for confusion to creep in
but you first have to agree on the
parameters of what it is you're trying
to fix only then will you be able to
find a path forward and some people to
help you do that
and go down down the road of counseling
and hopefully repairing your marriage I
really pray for you I hope it works out
for you finally last question from Erin
hi when arguing for the Second Amendment
as a defense against a tyrannical
government there is one argument that I
have trouble countering the argument is
since the government has presumably all
of the best weapons including nuclear
weapons what good would any weapon such
as an ar-15 do against that kind of
force Thanks we've been trying to occupy
Afghanistan here in the United States
we've been trying to occupy Afghanistan
for 20 years and we're about to leave
because we've been mostly unsuccessful
with that as a political matter and
there are military difficulties as well
Afghanistan is smaller than Texas and
the US government struggles to occupy
just that area and the Afghan Eze don't
have air 15's most of the time most of
the time they've got very old outdated
weaponry if we were in this doomsday
apocalypse scenario of a tyrannical
government we take arms against the
government first of all a ton of people
are going to leave the government side
and go fight with the people how many
people in the military do you think are
gonna stick with the government probably
not very many how many people in the
police forces probably not very many so
you've got that issue
you've got the political issue of
guiding the military because usually the
problems we have waging wars in this
country they're not the military usually
it's usually the politicians who oversee
the military and also it's a very very
big country that's what our politicians
are finding out right now and they're
trying to lock the whole thing
and tell us what to do and imprison us
in our apartments you're finding out
this is a very big country Americans
have a strong spirit of not being told
what to do and let's hope they learn
that listen now so they don't have to
learn it later all right that's our show
I'm Michael Knowles's the Michael Nolt
show see you next week
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin fenders
hair and makeup nikka geneva production
assistant ryan love the michael knowles
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]